das Community Video mit den außensitern
seid gespannt ob euer Kommentar eure
videofrage dran gekommen ist diesmal
also gebalte Antworten von Sascha und
Dima seid gespannt bis dann bleib
dran ich wambodu frage wie fühlt ihr
euch wenn ihr merkt dass immer weniger
sich für euch interessieren es gehört
dazu es gehört einfach zu YouTube zu der
Community dazu du kannst nicht immer
oben bleiben das Gehör dazu man geht
rauf und runter das Leben ist so es geht
immer rauf und runter fin sogar das ein
cooles Gefühl ist so mittlerweile dass
der Hype so ein bisschen runtergegangen
ist und dass wir unser Leben
einigermaßen ausleben können weil das
ist echt nicht normal gewesen jetzt ist
es cool jetzt macht's wieder Spaß Videos
zu machen Hallo meine Frage wäre was
haltet ihr von Star Wars und findet ihr
die alten oder die neuen Filme von Star
Wars besser möge machen mit euch
sagen also Star Wars ich will jetzt
nicht lügen deswegen werde ich auch
nicht sagen dass S mega Fans von Star
Wars sind aber wir haben alle Teile
gesehen wir haben Sie gern angeschaut
aber wir sind jetzt nicht so die
Menschen die sich auch T-Shirts anziehen
würden und dann so e du hast was
Schlechtes über Star Wars gesagt ich hau
dich gleich du Lappen das wür jetzt
nicht machen aber Star Wars ist ein
cooler Film und wir finden eigentlich
den ersten Teil am geilsten Episode 1
also Episode 1 ist die der beste
Teil bei den zweiten war ich enttäusch
bei den dritten auch irgendwie du hast
ein Star Wars T-Shirt zu
Hause schäm dich ich habe es dir zum
Geburtstag
geschenkt treibt ihr Sport und wenn ja
welchen das ist die Frage von Kings Eco
ja unser unsere beliebte Sportart
beliebteste Sportart ist im Internet
surfen surfen ist doch eine Sportart
oder Internet safen und dann also wir
fahren auch gerne Rat also um ehrlich zu
sein hallo lieber Außenseiter mein Name
ist Jimbo XXL und ich habe eine Frage an
euch nämlich wie ist die ach scheiße das
hatten wir schon
dann dann dann ja was würdet ihr machen
wenn ich euch eine Million Euro schenken
würde boah also ich denke mal wir würden
es nicht gleich so aus dem Fenster
schmeißen wir würden wahrscheinlich
es irgendwo einsetzen ja wir würden es
irgendwo einsetzen dein filmprodukt oder
vielleicht Musik genau ich würde mir
einfach ein gutes autotun kaufen endlich
mal ein richtiges Auto 2 nein ich würde
ich würde auf jeden Fall danke sagen GL
kann ich auch nicht singen die machen
das so professionell sie machen das
wirklich 20 Spuren autotun und der hört
sich danach an wie Saron nach
Flitterwochen mögt ihr Bratwurst sch
Schnitzel das ist die Frage von Werder
anfechter ich liebe Bratwurst vor allem
mit süßer Soße ich vermisse dich hier in
Düsseldorf we nein süße süße Soß sü süße
Senf genau süß Senf in Bayern gibt es
halt nur glaub die Frage ging gar nicht
an uns ich glaub das ist so eine
typische Frage oder so magst du brat
brwurst also du hast wahrscheinlich den
falschen erwartet beim Interview hast du
was verpasst ke ich mag ich mag keine
ich mag keine Bratwurst stell bitte die
Frage nie wieder
als meine Frage an euch wä was habt ihr
noch Großes auf Youtube vor ihr habt
jetzt schon den zweiten Film gedreht ihr
habt die 250 Videos erreicht ihr habt
dieses Buch rausgebracht was übrigens
ziemlich cool ist ja meine Frage ist was
habt ihr noch Großes vor ich glaube wir
haben das schon im Interview
angesprochen was wir so noch alles
erreichen wollen das ist also wirklich
kein kein so festes Ziel vielleicht
vielleicht ein Kinofilm was so
einigermaßen ein Traum ist von uns aber
so feste Ziele haben wir eigentlich
nicht wir wollen weiterhin Menschen
unterhalten wir wollen neue Sachen
ausprobieren und vielleicht irgendwann
im Hollywood sehen wir uns auf der
großen Leinwand oder vielleicht auch
unter der Brücke ist ja auch eine
Möglichkeit und wenn ihr noch mehr
Community Videos sehen wollt dann z.B
das mit alpagan wo er unter anderem über
seinen Beef mit Farid Bang spricht und
wie da die Lage ist
und noch eine interessante nutzerfrage
übrigens die an iBlali wo er über seine
Meinung zu coni
2012 spricht der ja gerade in Afrika
gejagt wird und da immer noch nicht Ding
festgemacht werden konnte also bis dann
bleib
dran